these are images released by what many
in mexico have dubbed a narco army
the video was published this summer by
the jalisco new generation cartel
these propaganda clips are a hallmark of
the cartel
which has grown into one of mexico's
most powerful drug gangs
so we consider this cartel new jalisco
to be one of the five most dangerous
transnational
criminal organizations on the face of
the earth
and it is doing unimaginable damage to
the people of
this nation in 2018 the u.s department
of justice listed the jalisco cartel or
cjng
among the top targets of international
counter-narcotics efforts
cjng has a presence in cities across the
united states
from san diego to omaha to roanoke
to new york city to orlando
we believe that they traffic at least
five tons of cocaine and five tons of
methamphetamine
into the united states every month
homicides and violence are at
unprecedented levels in mexico
and the jalisco cartel is a leading
culprit known to use
extreme violence to gain control over
new territory
this map illustrates the cartel's sphere
of influence
in their heartland of jalisco of course
they're pretty much untouchable
but for example recently they invaded
they they did a massive invasion of
zacatecas
zacatecas is now a hot spot of violence
guanajuato
is one of the most if not the most
murderous state in mexico
for the last two years before that it
was you know fairly well fairly far down
the list
it's very difficult to predict where the
handicraft will move next and where the
next
hot spots of violence will be but
certainly at this time they are
a considerable threat to national
security in mexico even the mexican
capital isn't spared from violence
linked to drug cartels
here the jalisco cartel is at war with
other criminal groups
including the powerful union depito
cartel
rodrigo who has asked us to hide his
identity says he's one of hundreds of
business owners who've faced threats of
violence
kidnapping and extortion from criminal
groups who he says are fighting over
control of parts of mexico city
[Music]
you may recall that a few months ago the
jalisco cartel put out a video saying
they would exterminate the union depito
and we're left here saying this is her
neighborhood this is in the battlefield
so this is what we're worried about
being caught in the crossfire
the jalisco new generation cartel has
made a point of making their presence
known in the city
in june cartel members launched a brazen
attack against mexico city's police
chief
security experts say that while the
mexican government could do more to
fight organized crime an all-out war
against cartel leaders
could have frightening consequences
manuel rapalo al jazeera
mexico city